you went on to say about authority over
women if I have a responsibility of it I
must have a degree of authority yeah for
the same reason if I have responsibility
over and people are going to lose their
mind it's an example an energy
responsibility over a child I have to
have some Authority so you believe as
part of your ownership or your property
of of the woman you have authority over
her no I believe if you ever that's what
you said I believe you've ever
responsibility over something you have
to have a degree of authority you can't
be responsible but Authority means again
that you're the boss the point I'm
making if you'll please let me finish at
this point the point I was trying to
make was talking about the safety of a
woman she was walking alone at night and
I was saying well I wouldn't let my
woman walk alone at night and they said
well you're not in charge of her you
don't get to decide what she does I say
I understand but if I'm responsible for
her safety and I'm the person who's
burdened with making sure she is safe I
have to have the authority to say don't
put yourself in unsafe situations the
two things are linked well you don't
have an authority you have the you could
absolutely have the right to say to the
woman you're with I don't think you
should but ultimately if she decides
that I can't force her right so
Authority implies that you have the
ability to control someone now Authority
believes the authority implies that I
have the moral right to sit and say that
that's an irresponsible thing to do and
I'm responsible that's not what
Authority means well I'm I'm not gonna
if you think I'm gonna lock somebody up
in their room if that's is that what
you're implying no I just think I don't
think you know what Authority means I
know what it means I'm saying that this
is a different description of authority
if I have responsibility for her safety
then I have to have the authority to
tell not to do unsafe but Authority
means that you have some form of control
over this woman
I I think you're trying to what you're
trying to I'm only trying to get to what
you think honestly I am I come with No
Agenda here at all I understand and I'm
explaining very very clearly if I have
responsibility of a said subject I have
to have authority of it so let me say
you have children right right you have
responsibility for them I have I have
legal authority over my children that is
very different having legal authority
over my wife or my female partner
completely but the point I'm trying to
make so you accept that I I accept that
you use the analogy of responsibility
for a child my friend these are these
are very these are actually really
important things they're important
things but you introduce you introduce
you interrupt me every five seconds so
it's hard for me to actually explain my
point the point I'm making here is very
simple you have children and you're
responsible for their safety so you're
gonna have authority to say don't go out
at night perhaps because you want them
to be safe you have legal Authority you
have a legal Authority yeah legal
Authority I'm saying that if I had a
woman and the question where you've
raised this sound bite from I was asked
about protecting a woman making sure
she's safe and I would say I wouldn't
want her to go out at night on her own
because I'm responsible for her safety
and someone said well
you don't have authority over it to do
that and I said well no I can't force
her to stay inside but if she were to
ask me how do I protect myself at night
I would say well you should stay inside
that's how you should do that's I don't
have an issue with so we agree no it's
the semantics it's not semantics and
this is what I don't think you quite get
why there's a fury over what you say
with respect because the semantics point
would be we're saying the same thing in
different ways but we're not I'm saying
to you that when you say I have to have
some authority over a woman I say to you
you have no right to any authority over
a woman you do over a child if it's your
child because you are the legal
appointed guardian of that child you're
not a legally appointed guardian or
authority over your wife or female
legally appointed absolutely not I agree
however
when it comes to things like personal
response or personal safety men largely
by Society are accepted we're the
protectors and providers we can sit here
and pretend in the world we live in if
me and my wife were walking down the
street and men were to come up and try
and attack us I wouldn't be the one
fighting but we both know in reality I
would right I have a degree I have a
degree of responsibility to protect her
survive a degree of responsibility to
protect her physically then the point
I'm trying to make is I will do my best
to make sure she's never putting herself
you wish you hadn't used the word
Authority The Authority is something
that she would give to me she would come
to me and say how do how can I make sure
I don't interrupt you I just want to
point out that's not what Authority
means if someone gives you can a person
can get voluntary Authority is not
Authority no but that's the point
Pierce if a woman comes to me and says I
want you to keep me safe she is handing
me Authority for her safety but do you
understand the difference between having
authority over somebody and somebody
giving you permission to have authority
completely I never said what is
consensual and one isn't but why are we
pretending I do unconsensual things
because you literally say I must have a
degree of authority I have to have some
Authority and the point only if I'm
responsible for her safety if I'm not
responsible if your position now is that
with her permission I would like to have
authority when we go out at night to
protect it that's a different that was
always my position that's not what you
said but that was always my position so
again I simply say to you do you it is
what I said do you wish you'd phrased it
a different way no because we're talking
about long format copy where I'm talking
about a woman who has come to me and
said you're responsible for making sure
I'm safe I said well then I have to make
the decisions but an 18 year old boy
reads I must have some authority over a
woman what do you think he thinks well I
understand that and I said this earlier
when you tried the sales backtracking
which I'm not doing no I'm not I don't
want to okay I'm not trying to gotcha
you cool I'm trying to work out exactly
what you I understand with massive Fame
comes massive responsibility I
understand that a percentage of the
population are always going to take
everything that's said by anybody out of
context would you change the wording of
what you said no I would just encourage
people to watch my long format copy and
understand would you tell an 18 year old
boy you don't have authority over women
absolutely you would say that unless a
woman comes to him and says you're
responsible for my safety please make
sure keep me safe about that Andrew Tate
I can sign up to well then we agree yeah
but I don't agree with what you said
before because you're taking a sound
bite from a two hour but you haven't
been taken out of context because I've
read you the entire sentence it's very
you've ignored all the contexts around
the sentence my friend you can't ignore
a sentence that says I must have a
degree of authority but you can win
there's a two-hour conversation where a
woman is telling me if she makes me
responsible for her safety and me
explaining well if I'm responsible for
your safety I have the authority to make
decisions yes you can order all the
contacts